نعم الجيش الاسرائيلي اعلن على ان عن
ارتفاع حصيله قتلى قواته خلال ال 24 ساعه
الاخيره بمقتل ضابط من رتبه رائد مساء امس
في الاشتباكات الدائره بشمال قطاع غزه
اضافه الى مقتل جندي متاثرا بجروح اصيب
بها قبل شهرين وذلك صباح اليوم وقال هذا
البيان الذي تم من خلاله اع الخبر على ان
سبب ال مقتل هذا الجندي هو اصابته
بتعفن فطري خطير و جراء تلك طبعا الجروح
التي كان قد اصيب بها ليرتفع بذلك عدد
قتلى القوات الاسرائيليه في قطاع غزه منذ
بدايه هذه الحرب الى
564 اضافه الى اصابه ثلاثه جنود وضباط
اسرائيليين خلال الساعات الار ال4 الاخيره
ليرتفع بذلك اجمالي جرحى القوات
الاسرائيليه الى
2828 منذ بدايه الحرب في اخر تحديث صادر
عن الجيش الاسرائيلي صباح اليوم اكد على
ان قواته ما زالت تواصل عملياتها ونشاطها
العسكري في مناطق متفرقه مع التركيز بحسب
هذا البيان على مدينه خان يونس وعلى غربها
وادعى هذا البيان على ان القوات
الاسرائيليه قتلت العشرات من المسلحين
الفلسطينيين وفق تعبير البيان طبعا اضافه
الى عثورها على مداخل عدد من الانفاق
وعثور ايضا على اسلحه ومواد ومعدات عسكريه
وايضا وثائق تابعه لحركه حماس من خلال
عمليات دهم لعدد من البنى التحتيه اضافه
الى ان هذا البيان قال بان القوات الجويه
الاسرائيليه اضافه الى القوات البحريه ما
زالت تجه ضربات مركزه بحسب تعبير البيان
لاهداف وصفها بال الارهابيه في مناطق
متفرقه من قطاع غزه طبعا كل هذا
وسط مواصله القياده العسكريه والسياسيه
هنا في اسرائيل التركيز على ان هذه الحرب
ما زالت متواصله بالرغم من الحراك الان
الذي يجري حول امكانيه التوصل الى صفقه
لتبادل الاسرى وايضا اعلان هدنه لوقف
اطلاق النار والجدل تدم ايضا
بخصوص الاسرى والمحتجزين الاسرائيليين في
قطاع غزه المتحدث العسكري امس مساء كان قد
اعلن مقتل
31 من اولئك المحتجزين الاسرائيليين في
قطاع غزه من بين طبعا
136 وهو ما يؤكد معلومات استخباراتيه كانت
في وقت سابق وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه قد
تحدثت عنها وتؤكد طبعا هذا العدد الذي
تحدث عنه التحدث العسكري مساء امس